hey what's up everyone good morning
happy Tuesday me and Jake are back
assuming you were here with us yesterday
for the Fire Emblem warrior stream but
we got a cool new game as I said this
week's gonna be pretty busy Jake yeah
and you kind of got to see this one
earlier last week so we got the right
guy in here to show you guys awesome
Assassin's Creed origins for all those
that are looking forward to playing the
game we're not doing any spoilers we're
not allowed to so we're gonna do a lot
of like side missions stuff invading
outposts may be fighting some animals or
something like that yeah I'll let Jake
Jake steer steer us there will be no
spoilers BPR gaming will go through some
of the like items that you know Matt a
Spinelli's gotten and some of the
abilities maybe some of the abilities
Jake feels are like pretty good if you
want to kind of like min/max
a little bit or something like that so
yeah I mean Jake would like I guess tell
me some of your thoughts on the game now
that you've played it and you know we'll
go from there um I don't know how much
I'm allowed to say in terms of like what
I think about it okay necessarily sure
however I can't say that it is a it is a
cool sort of fresh start to the
Assassin's Creed franchise and I think
if you like the other Assassin's Creed
games chances are you will like this
okay
you might find some things that you
think are rough about it but I mean all
in all it's pretty fun there's a lot to
it yeah we are in Alexandria Black
Knight yeah so this is like sort of the
central hub of the net mu not the
central hub but this is the big city of
the game actually we are allowed to show
the map now however ya know a lot of too
far a lot of it still isn't filled in
yeah so we're only in like what act to
reenact yeah just to give you guys a
little bit of a heads up of how far we
are not too far obviously but you said
Alexandra is pretty cool so we wanted to
start off here show you guys the city a
little bit then we'll kind of head to
one of those side missions or something
oh okay there's going on here that was
just some type of soldier we are playing
on ps4 Vita Rock xx Jake did play it on
something else last week but I don't
know if I'm allowed to say that so I'll
just steer clear of that I think we can
figure yeah exactly
no spoilers Mel got 12 we are just gonna
be roaming around doing side missions
just exploring the open world so like as
I mentioned guys no no worries from that
front if you have some questions I'll
point them in Jake's direction assuming
he's allowed to answer them if not he'll
just plead the fifth I'm also looking at
twitch YouTube and GameSpot chat as well
as I think we're even on Twitter today
so thank you guys all for tuning in if
you guys haven't subbed and followed us
already
to find out when we do yeah I saw her
fall down when we do these cool streams
you guys should do that cuz we're gonna
actually have a lot more streams today
it's gonna be a crazy Tuesday normally
we only do one stream a day every day at
11 but we got to stream assassin speed
here obviously a little early 9 a.m. for
us Pacific we're gonna do destiny to PC
launch at 11:00 with chasse T and we
have a special guest and then turns out
we can apparently stream Wolfenstein to
today too so we'll be doing that around
2 o'clock there's a lot going on this is
and then we'll probably up Mario
sometime into this week mariotta see so
a good time for gamers all around I
think yeah depending on what you're
looking for a difference
scratching different itches that's for
sure this is the big week yeah is a big
week for sure it's a big year yeah I
think it's been a big year it's been a
very big man so what's up anvil one game
Wow
Ryan Schubert in the house what's up
Ryan and what's up to some of the other
folks that I also might have
missed Jomar 9 5 5 sorry 9 3 5 3 harvest
the review will come I believe later
this week
I don't know if I'm allowed to say when
so I'm just gonna plead the fifth on
that one but it'll be later this week
probably before the game comes out this
guy's on to me is he I don't think so I
think he's just coming in for you to
easily kill him chest to the neck
it's spewed down yeah this is just like
an outpost I mean this is pretty like
typical pretty typical like Ubisoft sort
of take the outposts that's quite good
to get your XP up potentially get some
loot some objectives like it's there's
four treasures the loot won't want two
captains to kill and one commander to
kill we should be over leveled or at
least around the same level of this so
should be too hard but wow you just
served yourself up now yeah I see people
that are level 7 level 10 9 we're 20
right now so I'm hoping it shouldn't be
too much of an issue
I can't tell Chris Hawke doesn't believe
me that it's been a big year cuz he puts
it's been a big year question mark are
you kidding okay too bad that burb can't
poop on people so it's gravy biscuits
that I can't do this I didn't want to do
it cuz I didn't want to get notice but I
guess I can you can't as he sees the
body oh what's that
what why are you getting me a super bird
you stupid bird
see he does he actually the guy's got a
helmet up no no it's coming here now
that's okay oh just turn around that's
from above we'll do that yeah we'll do
the classic oh good there's a bush there
too
now worked out he didn't see his
peripheral vision is terrible you know
sharam galanga we were just putting on a
normal ps4 right now so nothing crazy so
yeah
a simple Khajiit catch it simple catch
it says why do I have to be in province
stats class while this just started
sorry man
try not to get in trouble watching this
I should actually advocate that anyone
in class shouldn't be watching but I'm
sure there's like a lot of people do
don't don't have the teacher tell them
that it was Eric Taylor Jake Decker that
caused you to watch this yeah that's new
right the numbers yeah yeah more like an
RPG yeah but yeah so those guys are
normally not too tough but they're kind
of tough you have to watch out for their
hits but they're bruisers so we should
be we're like level 18 or something like
that so these guys are like little 10
but as mentioned we have like three or
four side missions and then we can roam
around a little bit hopefully get some
hot loot I'm all about the loot Jake
loot there is definitely loot in this
game I don't know how much of its
worthwhile like okay like it was just
kind of throw away when you get a
legendary weapon though the yellow ones
it's usually worth holding on to those
because even if you do out level them
you can always take them to a blacksmith
and he can it's expensive but like it's
worth it because then they're kind of
like you know Destiny's exotics where
they give you perks that are kanai's
okay yeah I think they're saying that
like some of the weapons have like
elemental Oh what was that chain
assassination damn I don't know they're
like the other thing for me because of
the art like the action RPG RPG elements
of it is like I like seeing numbers so
it's kind of cool just like I don't know
yeah yellow for crit you know I don't
know it's probably just me I see yeah
Michael I like that as well yeah it's it
seems more in depth than maybe it
actually yeah no no it definitely is
just a visual thing but like I don't
know if there's something okay that is
the commander find satisfying woo about
the scene than numbers is there like a
parry okay sweet so is like dark kind of
Dark Souls II Dark Souls light yeah the
issue is I don't know Oh
it's over no it's not weapons loud baby
oh this guy's thinning hair he did the
old like my hair is thinning so I gotta
put one ran across my head alright I
don't think I'm not off yeah I think I'm
free no one noticed yes someone asked
about like real time real day stuff and
whatnot like weird you're not gonna talk
about any like spoilers or anything like
that I can't confirm or deny that also I
don't know if we're allowed to talk
about the density of content in the game
either okay yeah oh well I have no wants
to know can you turn off his elements
elements
I wonder if that's like do you mean like
all the HUD stuff I'm not sure let's
just keep going
your characters to Opie Opie right now
yeah um we'll try to find something more
of level I think I saw one of your side
missions was like 18 right yeah
definitely alright do you feel the game
is harder like then most assassin creed
Assassin's Creed's game that's tough to
say I mean it can be harder like oh god
hi this is great fascinate smoke bomb
it can be harder to get depends like if
you're over leveled like I am now like
it's gonna be really easy mm-hmm but you
can tackle any missions you want like
for the most part even ones that you may
be okay under level before but like the
odds are so stacked against you like
you'll do like ten damage to someone
who's like a couple levels above you oh
really couple levels okay I was just
saying I was wondering what that scale
was cuz usually like if you're like
within five and most like you know games
like RPG es games you're pretty okay
five this one for sure like if you see
like I think it's like a red skull then
it's like okay yeah so it's got that
traditional the red skull is very
traditional oh yeah we got some hot
action going on here
oh you've angered them yeah
ok so these are like yeah you really got
a big critic yeah it's a nice wide swing
alright who else someone else saw me all
the guys that we're supposed to buy me
time
oh sorry I missed a question can you
turn off those obstructive numbers is
that a thing yes you can you can sweet
okay get up on that mic Jake sounds a
little faded alright
thanks Scoob I'm fairly certain
difficulty option to someone was saying
there is difficulty option mat a we are
playing on ps4 when we post a review
later this week for Eric valera play
with no HUD is there a drawback to
playing with no hood yeah ok wait are
you are no hug yeah ok I was like oh he
didn't go no hug because there was no
prompt so that gets rid of all the
numbers oh that's how you would have to
do it I think you can move that reach ho
charge attack that's how you get rid of
this deal oh is that the commander I
think so
and he called some buddies or that guy
might be the commander maybe ok
god I don't even have what oh the
costumer put the HUD back on all right
there was you're like two minutes of no
HUD will do hey streamer where should I
look at the mini-map what was that even
mean
there is no mini-map okay there you go
I'm on minimal but I sure okay yeah
that's fine
I think that was the commander I feel
like hit me wrong stay on the ground
guessing there's like this is their
stamina no no okay all right why aren't
you looting I want to see some different
weapons the loot doesn't even show up
when I turn that off because we turn off
the HUD guys alright we turned off the
HUD guys because some people wanted to
see no hood and now everyone's freaking
out all right yeah are you playing at 4k
no we are not because I'm streaming at
1080 60
oh yeah that's loose guess I'm oh you
got a shield don't need that though oh
okay
can you play with anything else like a
spear yes you can play any other weapons
let's pretty much all right
Oh what's though I'm at I mean you'll
you probably do it later but what does
the r1r2 do is that like a super yeah so
it depends which weapon you're using
this one lets you basically powers you
unless you attack fast and each one you
said is different than right I I think
there's only two so there's this
something we just there's like a super
move you can do and actually we're gonna
see me fight a failing oh yeah all right
we got some of level foes here you guys
priests we sword - oh we shooting you
and he's not having you run away from
him probably should have saved your
super probably I'll probably eat it
pretty soon though yeah all right this
is this is what the people want to see a
fair fight okay I like how he talks crap
to you watch while that's happening of
course he's a boss got it alright I want
to get rid of this guy maybe he died
guys do you feel like are the Perry's
like worth it or is it kind of like not
worth it um I mean I can do a couple oh
god he's gonna use his that's it for me
oh all right well then so he did so that
was like the other sort of Ellen R or R
1 R 2 so there was like that powerup
thing that I did in there was the one
that feels like a super attack which I
didn't realize he could do and it took
down like half my health and one hit I
want to see the spirit well show you
some Spears after we get that guy
because he's gone now really mm-hmm
it's like come on man I can find him at
ye no no that's fine we'll deal with him
later is the hood toggle toggle a bowl
asked Jake Finley or does he always wear
the hood
it is talkable sure
just to show them that it's possible oh
damn he's got some rares that's hot I am
reading chat there's just a lot of chat
going on but yes please send your
questions usually putting question in
front of it will help me read the
question so there is still more loot
here okay
should I go sport or should we just move
on I just go for the party I think he is
the rebel yeah we're gonna want yeah
purple shield give me a spear I don't
care if it's not purple I'll get you
guys a spear oh how come you have two
weapons so it's kind of like have a
spear
here's even have a spear yeah why was he
using the pilum so you have two weapons
cuz you can switch between them so
here's my dual blade here's my spear
sick that's good I can do that with bows
as well okay
nice nice nice say hello please hi
Michael Jack Mikkel might be me kill
Steven Ortiz question how do you feel
about the new combat specifically the
color trail the sword leaves behind
effort every swing uh I mean that
doesn't bug me the combat is we've said
this before it's very similar to its
like dark souls and like the hitbox
detection I think I think it's fun but I
think it's like not nearly as tight like
it's still in the speedgame at the end
the day is like the evolution of that oh
yeah bird help us do you get more
damaged from the back do damage from the
back okay cool
Pokemon he was kind of okay that's good
we are currently playing on ps4 ravu soo
hello hang missile are you doing
well it's we'll check out some dual
wields action in a little bit Joker's
wild
i-i would totally rock to a wield that
time in my life equipped right now okay
fine great hamza attea wants to know can
you replay missions I actually don't
know I don't think so okay but I never
finished it maybe yeah I'm not sure
there are some cool missions though that
I'd like to replay and as zfk I don't
have the PC version so we couldn't play
it even if we want to right now uh what
level is back that you're playing at
we're probably like eighteen to twenty
twenty can you disable the shield I
guess when you do a wield is essentially
disabling the shield though right I mean
yeah I mean with so this I have dual
swords equipped right now when I block I
just hold up the second one instead of
the shields
question is this a pregame release I
mean we have a review copy if that's
what you're asking me
we're just allowed to show the game a
little bit early but no story spoilers
so obviously don't be worried about that
Josh lamer ask question how's the
difficulty with a new combat in this
compared to other Assassin's Creed's
other Assassin's Creed games is it
harder easier or what are your thoughts
it depends since it's more level based
and RPG it's it's more in the fashion of
an RPG it just depends when you want to
tackle a quest like if you're under
leveled for a quest it's gonna be a
little bit tougher if you're not there
like that for example that was pretty
easy because all those people were half
the level I am right now so it just kind
of depends when you want to tackle
things you can crank up the difficulty
though so if you are afraid of it being
too easy you can play it on I think I
think it's just like easy normal hard
they want to see how you took off the
hood I went to gear and then I just hit
toggle right there you go thank you
thanks for subscribing Jomar I don't
know [ __ ] young Kalonji
I don't know if Jake can speak to that
too much but they asked how do you like
the narrative so far yeah I don't know
if I can yeah I don't think we can talk
about that they want to know if there's
like multiplayer content no no
multiplayer there you go is gold the
best tier of game ask James Watt yes
right yeah that'd be legendary can't
talk about how long it's gonna take to
beat the game also can't talk about
level-cap maybe put ps4 in the title
okay I will update that harv s sounds
like a good suggestion
almost did PS dollar sign because I was
holding shift the best PlayStation
console I sure that that'll be the new
one yeah PlayStation money this is ps4
as as we just said I am going to put
that to the title to everything so
there's less confusion and so that
everyone knows what we are doing a
question how come only in our gameplay
is that the restriction for you actually
we can go up to roughly two hours we're
probably gonna play around 60 to 90
minutes somewhere in that time frame
depending on where we're at we we want
to show you guys as much good stuff as
we can but you know Nathan Drake asked
is there an in-game store what can you
buy I don't even know Oh thing yet I
mean there's a bunch of like vendors
throughout the game that you can go and
buy things with Gold's gold like that
you earn in the game or like
microtransactions gold the urine in the
game okay that's cool
why is my head bleeding PSN down asking
why are you playing this on a ps4 pro
we're actually just playing on a normal
ps4 because we're not shooting 4k
anyways so why didn't you do it on an
Xbox 1x didn't what didn't Microsoft
give me one cannot confirm or deny if we
have one or not yet and even if we had
one how why would they allow us to
stream it on that think about that
Jackie Mew as mentioned to unequip your
hood you just toggle it in your outfit
you literally hit triangle yep pretty
easy um this is a game only well I have
to ask you because I haven't played it's
not 30 right it 60 the game 2 fps oh it
looks higher than 30 from okay yes on
ps4 yeah it's I think it's higher than
30 but I'm not one of those people you
look at it and tell like I have
myself and it's very harder for you guys
to tell even on a stream yeah so someone
that was asking as it locks because it
looks like it slows down on the stream
so the cucumber man wants to know if the
map being so big is like a good or bad
thing I guess or is it too big so I it's
pretty big however I don't think you
necessarily need to go to all the
locations I'm kind of jumping around
this question because I don't want to
spoil anything yet but the map the map
is very big and it can be overwhelming
however if you don't want to go to all
those places you don't have to like you
can just kind of focus on the spots you
need to go I guess I think that's
probably the best way to put it without
right much okay
horizon down wants to know how's the
combat compared to witcher 3 is it
similar no it's very different okay can
you change your hair or beard not that I
know of unfortunately can the main
character ride a camel yes you can
I don't know if you can unequip your
shield completely Nick don't think you
can I'm not sure we answer that question
[Music]
how varied is the gameplay when you
switch between weapons I mean I'd say
it's it's it's like Dark Souls in a
sense that like they have like you play
differently obviously with like a spear
because you have more reach like you'll
wield you probably ought to be more
careful so like those so you've got your
strong attack which is R and you've got
your light attack which is or you guys
shrunk Tech which is R 2 and then your
light attack which is R 1 and so like
with this obviously I'm quicker and then
I can switch to my spear a little bit
slower but I've got it's like you get
wider tax longer reach yeah and then I'm
like the sword you know is pretty
standard what you'd expect again guys
for you guys for all the people that are
asking me questions in regards to like
story or anything like that I'm not
allowed to talk about anything story
related anything spoilery obviously we
could talk about some of the the game
mechanics and some general kind of
impressions nothing deep Tybee but we're
just basically doing side quest side
missions fighting stuff getting gear to
show you guys showing you guys different
weapon sets different kind of moves and
some abilities probably at some point
so I was trying to do before we started
but maybe we should climb the pyramid
that's kind of a cool thing to do Jacob
wants to ask Jacob how does it work when
you upgrade like your armor or weapons
and what kind of resources does it take
I can show that right now actually so
it's like changing your outfit doesn't
affect ooh damn game play at all like if
there's no there's no perks put it on
yeah but what you can't do is you can
upgrade your health by strengthening
your breastplate okay so it looks like
you have different materials someone
that looked like like hi so there's some
leather and another kind of leather like
alligator whether something like dice so
you do have to hunt the animals which
will do to animal hunting okay let's
question do you like the game so far
only Jake's played and I think he's
enjoyed it yeah like I said I don't know
how much I can say about that we will
have the review up soon yeah Jake just
disclaimer Jake is not the reviewer for
the game it's actually Alessandro in the
office he's actually already that yeah
getting that ready for the closer to the
end of this week so yeah we can go
through the inventory screens at some
point Alec maybe a little bit later so
that you know maybe it's like one of the
last things we do we can kind of get to
do a little deeper dive into the menus
perhaps I might be able to answer I I
can't but maybe Jake can answer this
basically some wants you to put your
hood for that outfit
that's Dillon just so we're gonna see
the full-on outfit but Jared Alvarado
wants to know how long or how hard
rather is it to get legendary gear oh I
wouldn't say it's particularly hard to
get legendary gear it just doesn't
happen very often
okay like it's a pretty random or yeah
it's a random so I think there are
probably certain quests that you haven't
chances of getting it are getting like a
legend okay got it like certain like
maybe fighting certain people or
something yeah
however like I'll open up a chest and
they'll be yeah like when I was playing
last week I got I think one of my
favorite weapons in the game so far and
I just continued to upgrade it but I
just got it completely randomly Dionne
Albert with the question why isn't there
a carrying capacity why isn't there a
stand well like well most RPGs I'm
guessing that's just a design choice
they wouldn't want yeah I mean other
than that I don't really have an answer
since I'm not a dev is there play move
666 wants to know is there rewarding
exploration yes that is one thing they
have added about to this game that was I
guess kind of any other ones but as you
can see the compass up top mm-hmm was
different check marks or question marks
you can go to and they can be anything
they can be like tombs they can be they
can be quest they can be I don't know
it's it it it's completely rant and not
random but like you have no idea like it
do this here just like a point of
interest or something right that you
should maybe check out yeah we did equip
the hood we can show that and you want
to spin around for it like so we'll give
it 15 seconds all right do the classic
spin around Dark Souls show off armor in
cool setting thing sorry that we're like
so this this this had come up the other
day we're like I was comparing a game to
Dark Souls and people were like some
people in chat were like not too
thrilled of the fact of that because
it's like kind of like a generalization
at this point that like we call things a
certain way but I was telling them that
it's just a way to help convey a point
to help people understand I guess and
maybe because like I feel like Dark
Souls is kind of like a genre now in a
way which is like weird to think but so
if anyone's mad about that sorry but
it's the easiest way to kind of describe
something like that yeah I'm not happy
that I refer to this the combat similar
to Dark Souls like what else do I
compare it to that most people
then I guess at least have a general
understanding of it I guess I got to
think back at like other games of that
type I guess because it definitely isn't
Devil May Cry yeah definitely not like
The Witcher or older Assassin's Creed
games yeah man it must be hot as heck
inside that helmet yeah probably that's
probably why we had the hood off but
everyone in chat was like now we gotta
see that sick I don't know as a lion
mask or some torture for byuk and he's
fine he's used to the heat
sci-fi video games wants to know how is
the AI in the game uh I mean the people
it's fine like the people you're
fighting like do things they should do
when you're fighting the people roaming
around like sometimes you can be kind of
dumb like that
yeah sorry go get run over by horses as
we saw like at the beginning and oh my
god don't miss
like that one level Tony guy seemed like
he was doing you know a decent
combination
yeah like attacks and he knew what he
was doing yeah so that it seems like
it's pretty like at least from the
minimal minimal enemies I've seen so far
at least it looks like it's tuned pretty
well in terms of like like you're what
you're fighting based off like level I
guess yeah alright for all the people
are asking about the shield I guess svr
nasi es bit as said you cannot remove
the shield don't know if they know that
for sure but kind of seems that way
as mentioned early yet no uh there's no
here we are co-op I don't even know if
the in-game shop exists right now so I
don't know if I could show you that I
mean I think it does alright
we this isn't menopur win this isn't
like save where we like beat it the game
and kind of came back so we don't have
like all the like outfits you couldn't
obtain so this is a Matt Espinel ease
account and he had one outfit do you
know where you get this one from or is
it just like yeah this one's quite face
nice impleaded quest but we can you can
shop with our outfits ok car will us-23
asking is it playable already or do you
have special access we have special
access this is like a review copy
essentially so yeah in three days it's
gonna be out we just we're able to
stream about you know an hour hour and a
half here we have a little bit more time
than that but we also got a to put some
other stuff up so and do some other
things today so that's kind of where
we're at
alright we'll check out some crocodiles
there is no co-op mode Mac ffs do 9 I
think there was a question about HDR
support I'm not sure if you know or not
go yeah I don't know I'm pretty sure
there is for like pro and x1x
okay hyena
yes getting that you didn't get a hide I
did oh there you go
what's that what's that plus one purple
hyena this is the rarity of what I took
from it I guess okay nothing nothing
that cool alright Adriano Burroughs was
asking about difficulty in the game I
think as Jake alluded to earlier it
depends on what you're tackling and like
you know in comparison to what your
level is but there's also like a
difficulty slider so you can make it
harder if you feel like it's too easy
for you so that would be my best answer
I think he said like even within five it
could be like if you're less than five
it'd be kind of difficult and there are
like ways the game kind of tells you
like hey this is a Red Skull it's
probably gonna be really hard yeah do
you get like two shot by those kind of
guys or okay who is this oh wait are we
hunting a croc yeah
swim to your death oh you almost
snatched at that I don't know bird him
in the head for like what would you say
is the most dangerous like predatorial
animal okay that I don't know if you can
talk about all the animals but like
usually like leather aren't that big of
a deal it's when you have to fight
multiple ones where things get tough
vision look at all those hides you could
get um go for some more I don't know
it's totally up to you is there is there
like a hippo around it's hard to say
actually you know we can do what can we
do we're gonna steal this transport we
want a leap of faith now there are leap
it the leap of faith isn't definitely in
here yeah yeah I mean we can do that as
well I gonna say I doubt it cozy but
they asked if we could go to the fight
pit hello oh dang it's level 20 moves
okay headshot does a lot in this outfit
though I kind of I kind of like that
loop gets me so easy Jay oh no man think
you're gonna try it yeah I think so I
mean I think so like some of the loot
you get like some of the weapons
legendary weapons you get her actually
like really cool like they're not just
like oh here's a slightly better weapon
like they have some really cool effects
nice can you talk about those effects uh
I mean I can talk about the ones I know
of yeah like Alessandro found one that's
cursed and basically it Third's your
health it's only if 130 risk/reward but
it does three times damage okay that's
pretty cool
I'll give you some hard mode later
sci-fi video games oh is hard though
like hard as you can pick okay let me
see if I can even change it at this
point it may only be like when you first
now you got to be able to we'll find out
oh yeah so there's normal hard and easy
to hard yeah let's try some hard looks
like good luck
oh those are nice I can check that out
later
well we'll do like a menus thing later
after the end or something when we do
like look at gear and abilities and
stuff fit in 76 XS 20 minutes till
destiny peace PC destiny - PC launch
yeah enjoy that have fun Archangel wants
to know how dual-wielding is I guess
here's a blanket question I did like the
weapon types you have fought with what
is your favorite I guess I like the good
old sword and I would like the axes okay
why don't you unequip the spear and
equip the axe so we can see something so
assuming he has an axe I don't know if
he does it's really cool oh yeah you're
playing hard - huh the dual blades -
alright fine well show awesome dual
blades so he likes it for the person
asking about dual weight dual wheel to
combat will do a leap of faith - since
we are right next one how is it without
the mini-map I like that it's gone I
haven't had an issue so now you're on
minimal right
yeah minimal HUD I mean there is no
mini-map even if you turn up all the
hood okay it's just that compass here we
go
system of the world and then turn it up
so we can hear that eagle screech you
got it
[Music]
there it is all right you got the iconic
the Eagle there are the colors for
weapons sort of like for tonight
ask Wayne Lloyd yeah it's pretty much
like most RPG games you have like is
there even green or is it just blew a
bowl Gold okay so blue purple gold
that's why I like is it rare epic
legendary I just get I'm just basing
that off like yes being like that
I can probably look I guess try to cut
off this transport do you think the
combats more like Dark Souls or horizon
zero dawn I don't know
I mean horizon zero dawn like was mostly
range combat true and like the close up
stuff in horizon zero dawn wasn't that
good and I would say it's better than
the than that you know that yes I can
one shot that's good and they can't come
on horse there we are policy scared them
off deandre Yahoo Davis you're welcome
we're privileged enough to play and
we're happy that you guys are all able
to tune in hang out with us check out
some Assassin's Creed origins
you know like side missions exploring
the world as mentioned earlier no
spoilers here on this stream gonna be
going for at least an hour not a little
bit more and as mentioned we have other
streams today to which is gonna be
pretty insane so gonna be an insane day
here for for some of us here at the
office
we got destiny to launch screen PC
launch screen here and at 11:00 a.m.
which is an hour and 15 minutes from now
and then at 2 o'clock we're gonna be
playing some Wolfenstein 2 so stay tuned
and come back for that if you guys have
the time but either way me and Jake
appreciate you guys hanging out with us
while we fight on horses in hard mode
better to use from horse oh he's got a
spear too but you took him down no big
deal so what do you get for you got some
iron
yeah would you need to probably mm-hmm
black Smith it up poison donut asking a
pretty pretty good question will the
game force me to switch weapons often or
can I stick to my favorite in stick to
your face oh so I mean you will get
better equipment as you play but usually
like if you want to use swords you'll
get a steady stream of swords so you can
keep using swords or can use axes you
can get a steady stream of axes and if
you do get a legendary like I said you
can go to the blacksmith and he can
upgrade it you can reforge it to to
essentially like make it useful even
when you get to higher levels does that
cost like gold so it is like currency
based not like material base okay what's
up Joe Joe al Vitor sorry if I butchered
name and long Tran what's up this is
just the og it's not a pro oh hippo
hippo murder yeah look at him easy angry
okay all there's two there's three oh
there's three yep okay they're slow slow
yeah they're hard to dodge though
because they can attack your trading
yeah look at that wide swing of the
spear I've never been a spear guy in
other games but this it's pretty solid
like I didn't the first time using it
and I actually kind of liked it well
that is the what so the one game that
came out earlier this year that I
enjoyed that it actually kind of wanted
you to switch weapons even though you
didn't have to was a neo and I felt like
I was messing around with more weapons
in that game than I did in like a like a
blood-borne our Dark Souls but that's
because they had like weapons and
specific like skills and stuff you could
upgrade I'm guessing there this is just
like but each weapon has its own kind of
specific move set yeah
light and heavy attack this guy just
living up life
and I come in here yeah you're just
doing a nice little bath sleeping oh you
know what oh okay I was about to say
hard doesn't seem that bad because when
he hit you with his head and only took
off like one little square of your 15
squares but some of these attacks hurt
oh that did not kill there we go that
looked cool though does it always look
like that or is it different for each
weapon that's like the powerful strike
it's different for each weapon yet if it
has the powerful strike like like I said
some will have the like superpower
charged up sort of thing mm-hmm
alright I don't know if we can actually
upgrade our thing now now we need soft
bloody damn soft leather yeah triple Cup
Chuck why aren't you all playing on an X
that is not even out yet doesn't come
out till next month
don't call PETA chosen please just don't
hmm where should we go we can venture
into some higher level stuff all right
let's do it
we'll start with hard not afraid we'll
go to Memphis first okay this isn't to
high level stuff good it's around what
you are right so it's around what we are
but we can go through Memphis to the
next area Memphis is one of the big
cities in this game it's very cool
also a lone gamer makes a good point
you're watching in 1080p though for a
hippo so it's like I don't even know if
we would stream 4k because that [ __ ] is
not that's pretty tough and then like I
don't even like out of the people that
are watching I'm actually curious how
many people actually have like a 4k TV
I personally still don't have one I
think I'm waiting for the costs to go
that the costs have gone down quite yeah
like I was actually looking at one this
weekend huh 500 bucks is not bad it went
under like did that have HD are those HD
are okay yeah alright so they're getting
they're becoming more normal and TV
pricing which will then probably lead me
to get one and then and that'll be what
I am is you're looking for like a huge
one then it's still pretty dang expand
like I feel like anything under like 55
inches isn't yeah too late and 55 inches
is bigger than all ever need to be
honest it also depends on like your room
sighs - it's like you don't want a 55
inch and like be like right next to it
obviously I also don't have anything
that can do 4k at the moment like my PC
doesn't even do for ya but I'm because I
because that's like that that's the
thing right it's like okay so you're
buying not only the console but you're
also buying on TV and that's the problem
for me is okay well then at that point
you're shelling out a thousand bucks
roughly right cuz like the game system
the TV and then like you know buying the
games that you want to play as well but
you know we're slowly getting there I
guess
turns it the technology
Tanishq a Raj Singh question does this
game give us that same Assassin's Creed
feel that depends what your what your
idea of Assassin's Creed is I mean it's
still very like the setting is the
coolest and probably most important part
of the game which I always thought was
the most interesting thing about
Assassin's Creed games however if you're
in it for like the story or combat
I mean they've definitely changed things
around a little bit but I think overall
it has that Assassin's Creed feel some
guy didn't believe the $500 with HDR 4k
TV I think it's actually possible like
like Jake said as if I think it's closer
to like the 40-plus inch like around
that 40 inch maybe 55 inch sizing and
then it depends on the brand at that
point obviously - I feel like well do
you remember what it was was it like a
lg Vizio so it was one of the cheapest
ones I saw on Amazon oh god I got it it
was it was probably like some crappy
off-brand
yeah the gesture wants to know are there
any one-handed axes or dual axes
I don't think there are any dual axis
but there are one-handed axes I believe
or that maybe not one-handed axes but
there are I can pull it up there are I
guess I think these are these one-handed
I feel like the heavy the ones I say
heavier probably to hit well we can go
unarmed sick do you ever get like
upgrade for that
I don't think so damn come on come on
there's got to be a punchy punch kind of
thing is there we'll check that out
later actually
come on actually curious to see if that
there's something there yeah you got a
circle the dive ooh yeah loot crate good
job Jake it's like you're your loot
sense kind of popped - no there's more
treasure is there yeah it said one of -
yeah I get that vision get that loot
vision as long we call it danker for
pony house fighting multiple enemies it
looked pretty hectic I think it depends
on what kind of stuff you're fighting
yeah it depends how many like there's
like if you're fighting like four or
five it's not too bad but anything more
than that it can be kind of a mess it
like did look kind of there is it did
look kind of annoying to have to deal
with like you know of a big bruiser kind
of guy heavy blunt yeah and then also
have like a couple range guys just kind
of like you know skirting around while
you're trying to deal with the big guy I
don't know I think it depends yeah sigh
optic gaming are there loading screens
between areas or completely open world
it's completely open world unless you
fast travel then you will have a loading
dodge won't you equip what do we get we
got the heavy blunt right oh the bone
cracker oh they're all bone cracker
anyways there we go - that's got to be
two-handed right find out find out yeah
we did climb the pyramid speedo W if you
actually scrub back a little bit maybe
like 10 minutes ago we'd climb the
pyramid there at that point
see it to the person that said goodbye
said it was laggy for them on the stream
I'm hoping it's just as Internet but
most people haven't liked complain too
much we're gonna go - thanks Harv yeah
we try to get as many questions in as
possible / answers in obviously
dependent on if Jake can answer them
yeah we can show how big the map is in a
little bit because we're probably gonna
just run through the menus at some point
for you guys and then we'll just take
all the menu questions at that point I
guess maps menus what's with that sale I
don't know it's a ghost sale I guess
yeah I think it's just so you can see
thank you for the people that are saying
it's not laggy AB de Luna as well as
ruthless Walshy I'm pretty sure it's
part of that's internet pro like I think
what this is just a little rant as a
person that helps a stream a lot here at
GameSpot I think people sometimes don't
realize that some of like the the I
wouldn't say technical difficulties of
streaming but like there are some things
that are controlled on your guys's end -
in terms of like your PC or CPU or laps
or it's not CPU but your PC or laptop
connects an internet connection there's
so many factors are you on a phone you
know what I mean like on a phone
actually like apparently on a phone
there's really no reason to like go
higher than 720 like 60 like you can't
even tell at that point it's like wasted
resolution but anyways sorry
rant over I ran over a crocodile that
was did you get this oh we're going to I
didn't even see that you're going to a
higher place I thought you're hanging on
Memphis where you're of level now we
went we blew right past Memphis oh okay
all right well we'll see how it goes I
probably won't last we'll try to go find
some outfits in a little bit to like
check out
yeah there's probably a merchant here
that we can look at sweet slam bam a
gorilla man thanks yeah he said that
person's internet probably was just not
good it looks crispy for him that's
always good we will show the map there
was a question and I I'm sorry that I
didn't catch the username there but they
wanted to know if it's the biggest map
in AC history it has to be okay um
I off the top of my head I mean maybe
black flag was bigger but that's just
because there was a lot of like open
water mm-hmm
but pull it up I'll just show it again
like it is it is huge like we're in this
little section right here yeah
we've traveled from Giza down to here
damn but there's so much more okay yeah
it looks like the person that said for
you for max level must be pretty on
point cuz that's kind of what the map is
showing so there you go there's there's
the map but yeah I feel like open games
yeah there is this is very open Jim
Brower oh sorry go ahead
apparently there are some sections that
are just like desert and there's not a
whole lot there but I mean who knows
yeah gene Brower says 720 not good for
phones although my 8 has Samsung NSA it
has a higher res than 1080p yeah well
fine
gene most phones not like the newest
version of a samsung phone how's that is
that fair
we will show outfits don't wear it or
not and all the other people we will we
will get to that we can try to show off
some picture mode later too if we if we
have time we are playing on just a ps4 a
min I'm pretty sure you definitely can't
smoke the heavy blunt I was waiting for
that question some people asked about
the voice acting well how do you feel
like it's uh oh it's a one hander
it is want it or no you two handed it
there that was weird
but like maybe the heavy hold up
um I think the voice acting for the main
characters is pretty good like the
characters you hear walking or like when
you walk around and hear a character
talk it can be pretty bad okay weird
thanks for all the kind words guys
trying to get through as many requests
as we can obviously if we miss something
or if I miss a question or anything like
that
apologies I will try to get back to them
as soon as I can can you explain the
damage numbers at the bottom of the main
menu let me pull the main menu and I can
take a look at okay sure do this little
spin thing sick in gear melee damage oh
so this is how much damn heavy and light
my first one and that's what the second
one will do oh god it's like I think
blood-borne did that too right how your
a weapon that was kind of yeah that was
kind of a weird one word like yeah we're
like your primary would do more than
like your secondary so there's that
screech again alright let's see hey X
the only character right like the main
character yeah he's he's the main care I
just asked because someone asked if you
could play this as a female and I don't
use the main carry so DM youtuber HD
will you listen to me well it depends on
what you're trying to tell me yeah it's
like a giant horse from like Zelda it
just looks so big compared to like the
people I guess on the floor I know they
were did you find like they began in
horse sad thing was huge
I mean did you are you feeling any FPS
or frame drops at all no it seems pretty
solid to me okay so if you're happening
to see anything it's either like the
stream because you know we still are
streaming out to you guys or it's
potentially your connection on your ends
potentially I'm not saying that it is
for sure that crock a skull croc yeah
and we run hard look how much damage
it'll do it shows you yeah so you just
can't see cuz come on come here oh man
Jake he doesn't want to mess with me he
knows he'll just kick my butt he's like
you're not even worth this time are you
just trying to show how hard it is at
like eight level 30 yeah premise of
coming here I guess okay oh there we go
I learned something
that's a weird where is it because it's
definitely not that guy oh it's behind
you
all right skull croc who will win Jake
oh there's two of them Jake oh so good I
did no damage it's still good
so we're 13 levels below give or take oh
geez I don't like your chances Jake just
being honest here oh maybe yeah I see
that other croc No
No hit it yeah you do any pickle them
you tickled him in before rip
no yeah we ribs don't fight skulls guys
red skulls are bad in a lot of games it
is literally I feel like the new
indicator for you should not fight this
thing yeah I believe review embargo will
lift sometime later this week before the
game actually comes out so that's the
best I can give you guys Dave dad yeah
no worries on the on the maps we try it
like it like we said or I said we try to
get back or explain or ask as many
questions as we can our - mekt
I'm guessing tomb explorations is what
Goliath 11:08 0 is asking then they
bring that back yes there is - Mexico
there you go it's kind of like Tomb
Raider in a sense there's like little
puzzles sometimes you have to do can you
guys please show us more outfits yeah
I'll do that now at least he didn't
write in in all caps oh I know he did
write in oh yes that's why I saw it
don't write in all caps though please
we're gonna have to do another loading
screen and so I can get out of here Oh
Jake it's too late
that's fine that's fine it's okay is
there some kind of class build I mean
there's class abilities you feel like
the class ability like are there ones
that are better than others yes
definitely better than will you
eventually get them all I knew it is it
like a shadow of war shadow of mordor
thing we're like you're eventually gonna
get everything or do you still have to
be kind of slow I think you can get
everything but it's gonna take a lot of
time and grinding most people will
probably want to focus on a certain
skill tree but just because you focus on
one skill tree doesn't mean you can't
pop on over to another one and like kind
of cherry pick the ones you want from
each side yeah yeah but I can show there
is like paths though you have to have
like certain things among other things
we showed Alexandria earlier so if you
scrub back in the back oh we're back
okay we're back so we can check it out
now and we can check out outfits so
we showed the map as well so you just
gotta scrub back a little bit I saw
someone a question are there new
gameplay mechanics in this game or is it
still just one button to counter like
before other stuff that is new based on
this gameplay it looks pretty recycled
from previous and that was from knob
junk the the car it's not just one
button to the counter like the combat is
way more involved this time around you
control every swing you have to you have
to keep in mind the hitbox like how how
much range your weapon has that sort of
thing but like these the climbing and
sort of the feel of it like get up on a
big tall building and synchronize is
very Assassin's Creed II we're
definitely not going to burn the Library
of Alexandria sorry that's cool if we
could but someone asked if you could so
there you go you can't what is the
highest point in the game I think the
Pyramids of Giza alright so we kind of
did that right I mean maybe there are
mountains that are higher that you can
get into but I think building wise no
multiplayer le park kids all right I
tend to buy from the Weaver ooh
coastal address of the coastal realm
well that's kind of cool
like that is that is that all she has so
- okay
there's no one else that sells outfits
there are other people in each town but
they're the same just different colors
and what I found at least but you can
get other outfits from quests and stuff
like from the quests and like just by
completing like Alessandra found a
really cool outfit for doing something
yeah I forget exactly what he was doing
but yeah I'm sure the shop will have
some as well cuz the outfits are just
aesthetic right like this yeah so that's
probably what this store will sell I
think last week I saw Assassin's Creed
team themselves did a kind of like a
pre-release stream and I think they
showed off like this crazy-looking
anubis one which was like pretty cool so
I'm fine with cosmetics they don't have
stats right so
yeah so they don't have stats so
basically I mean you know enjoy that
it's fine people want me to go to the
Fight Club I think to or the the arena
is that a thing that we can do it's a
thing I don't know how to get there I
know we're just gonna not oh I know
something I can do though okay sounds
good let me take we're gonna take this
applet outpost first okay and then okay
What's Up mo car II dive probably
definitely probably definitely not
ancient strip clubs sorry my hammer man
there is a bathhouse though let's go at
it but I'm pretty sure everyone is close
uh uh well then there you go that's the
closest you're gonna get there actual
differences in weapon arts although it
did look like oh geez Wow
night we're like eight levels higher
than these guys so we're doing the polar
opposite now instead of getting smashed
we're smashing them but we are playing
on hard so if you're over leveled you're
still very strong
obviously you're definitely not gonna
kill us it's just I okay knocks them
dude I will say this and maybe this is
just me noticing it but at least the
having this heavy blunt it like he I can
hear and and feel kind of the
weightiness
all the weapon which is cool shakes yeah
whereas like with the quick blades it
wasn't doing that so at least I can
appreciate that quite a bit
BAM is there like a commander guy at
this pose there is okay cool
cuz I want you to use okay or you could
just do it now
right there I was gonna have you do the
power stroke just to see if it was
different oh look this guy thinks this
dual deal is any good about to get
rocked oh wow
that was brutal yeah you did not need to
do the uppercut but uh we liked the swag
there okay definitely can't fight Hitler
in this one that definitely can't it is
not a ps4 pro-west this is just a normal
ps4 for all those that keep asking or
and/or don't understand if it was a ps4
Pro I would have put ps4 Pro in the
title I only put ps4 alright yes I do
have a heavy blunt okay and so here is
one of the mini game like things in the
game Oh mini game sick checking out a
mini game I played it for about 20
minutes didn't get super into it but we
can definitely you know what would have
been good like you can't access your
menus or anything during the load
screens right I don't think so no okay
what's this Hippodrome Oh French
challenge may be okay she's too good
that's too good that's too good alright
we'll do a tournament tutorial race
Nikes winged victory I guess do you
think there's a guy named Mikey back
down I so the shoes are named after Ingo
flamingo we'll check out the screen a
little bit and then I'll have Jake kind
of pick what he thinks is his favorites
or go twos I'm probably gonna lose this
but hey you can try it I forgot how to
play
artists come on that guy's bumping you I
here we go then the red end and done man
how are you gonna take this turn Jake oh
nice oh you let the guy take the inside
on you pom-pom into that thing like
gladiator oh they got you got help bar
too huh in Forza you would have lost so
many or Forza and in Gran Turismo you
would have lost so many points for all
that bumping but this is this is some
old-school racing here yeah I think we
got to get more physical because clearly
you're not gonna win with just your
normal racing skills I feel like oh this
guy's all over the place
I don't know how to ram people alright
lap 2 of 3 you're like somewhere between
second and fifth because clearly first
place racer is just a god
oh thanks making a play chase Jake is
making a play here okay Jake sprint all
about that inside corner his horses seem
to be doing all right kind of wide oh
all right you just got keep it up you
just got to keep it up ben-hur status
here fine a lot let's go you got it just
stay calm cool you got a rear view
mirror or anything no you let him take
the inside I think he's got it now
unless you can find a way to take him on
the next turn here oh man you went from
first to third it's all getting real
dicey oh oh got a real dicey come on
Jake hold strong do you have a night not
nice button out of what six not bad not
good enough though three points race
with one of three oh there's three races
does it differ is there like more stuff
in the way I don't know I I only did the
tutorial next race then let's go
Assassin's Creed Troy
man we need to draft more yes kxk we
didn't draft enough sure I think yeah
yeah can you upgrade the horses
so probably haven't done enough of the
raisin this is like those walrus races
in the breadth of the wild I have
freaking seems like that it's so bad I
don't even think I got that shrine
because I just got frustrated I always
got like second oh I don't know how to
oh that's that was pretty good that's
real good because like you cut them off
kind of why was that do like drift yeah
this is not the pre-release demo yeah oh
you need a little slide I kind of missed
I was looking a chat my bed
there's no console war stuff going on
guys relax
unless the horse behind me is named
consul then there's a yeah that that's
true
let's get first we're trying oh yeah
yeah yeah oh this one comes up out of
nowhere
he's today though that's a day give him
that a hot square action yeah now we
know what we're doing yeah
[Applause]
come on the pest and the furious darn
right Eric will air this is where they
fought this this is where they find the
streets before they've played for horses
not for pink slips
unless there's pink slips for horses but
oh no the turn was wide okay nice
can you hold on though I like that angle
you take that like I made sure the
horses we're like in front oh man hey
you gotta do what you gotta do uh hey
does anyone there at Gamestop miss cow
said of course we missed cam said Tyler
putzie we all we still do work with them
actually they they yeah they're honoring
you through stage they still do some
chronic contracting stuff if I could
talk for us so you'll you'll see them
every now and then on the game spa
Channel there we go sandstorm that
edited it and this time they've done
edited it arm so sorry I'm in it I'll
just see myself out Michael wants to
know is there a non-lethal pack they
took out that uh I don't know what those
things are called
oh you're just driving that guy into the
wall oh man your rugged racer this time
yeah that's it so I'm guessing it takes
all three races into account at the end
right yeah so it looks like five for
first place do you know what the reward
was or did you only oh you said you only
did one practice I didn't as an assassin
can you cheat in a horse race I don't
know how you would unless you brought
out your bow and arrow but then how
would you also like whip your horses to
run faster unless he was a one-hand God
maybe he could throw like throwing
knives or spears while he's yeah Maximus
style
[Music]
all right here we go big turn here and
that guy is racing the race of his life
right now final lap this is like Usain
Bolt oh here we go we're drafting him
we're drafting he feels the pressure of
the horses
oh no no no Jake that sandstorm turn too
early and it's okay I think I think you
can potentially okay maybe not try to
get third I would say now one wide turn
really wanted you but I feel like you
know the inside track oh the horse is
kind of like his head hit the wall but
he somehow managed to survive all right
we got boring that might cost us
sorry it's a chariot race you're right
but still yeah he's got a point okay Wow
hundred gold is that good all right cool
yeah we want to get oh yes sick
bender baby
all right should we do all the menus and
all that kind of stuff yeah let's do the
menus and oh yeah well there's one menu
we definitely can show uh
ooh I wonder says the lag is hardcore
for him I think it's the stream it's
totally fine for us here in the game in
person but I don't know I've heard I've
heard varying things from the stream
some people are complaining about it
some people are like no it's crispy so I
don't know what to say about that so
I'll just tell you that for us here
solely fine I haven't really seen any of
the drops or lag or anything that you
guys are talking about so take that it's
quite summation time here yeah yeah but
we're learning hot hints fire arrows and
whoa royal baby food it is likely that a
wet nurse took care of Cleopatra that's
a servant pre-chewed food when she was a
baby and they had royal damnit I got you
guys it's a chariot race my bad because
the horse race is only one horse the
chariot race has four and you're
actually in that thing get on that horse
Bojack horseman Bojack horseman alright
we're going to check out some of the
menus alright I'll start with inventory
let's do it
I mean I I think the reason there's no
like wait necessarily weight limit is
because those items yeah I mean that
you're not picking up everything like
you wrote you would be in like a Witcher
or a Skyrim instead it's like these are
the main resources you're gonna get and
there's quest items do you feel like you
ever run out of arrows or is that the
time like okay all the time yeah that
maybe you can upgrade it so you can get
bigger bigger arrow things arrow Quivers
here's the skill tree so like we're
saying before you can pick between
warrior seer and hunter hunter's morbo
and stealth or your is more close up and
personal seer is more like using the
environment to get things attack you for
it to attack enemies for instance you
can like yeah once you chose one of
those videos or something an animal
drinks you can oh yeah white tiger tiger
yeah
and poison dart I mean I guess there's a
sleep dart so if you want to go then
non-lethal right night to do that
smoke screen they said berserk is that
like a like a buff the one makes is a
snake dart thing right below with the
skull and the swirlies sorry yeah oh you
can turn them against their allies okay
yeah okay cool so yeah this one's more
like using everything else yeah yeah
and then warrior like I said like you
know is this chain throw power Oh what
does that do I think you that's what you
did earlier that was a double
assassinate oh I did that but with yeah
it was like it was an assassinate
ability this one seems to be a like
actual warship overpower someone you can
immediately go to awesome
and it looks like Matt hasn't put that
much in he's not a bow guy I'm all about
that I'm a bow guys he's all about the
melee cool overnight yeah so you've got
your a and B slot you have to get a perk
to unlock the B slot for both of these
you start out with just one is there is
there only bows as ranged weapons in
this game like there's not like a jackal
using the Jackals gaze come on Matt when
you see yellow you gotta use it sorry
sorry I'm putting him on blast like my
bad he'll fun hit so that's like pretty
good yeah endowed with the power of the
god Anubis maybe we should try that out
before oh he's got two oh come on
okay well this is yeah that's really
good okay or shouldn't you put the
audience in a okay good good good
alright the mount by who the wanderer
sorry it looks so dumb
and then stabilizer go of this is
increased range damage arrow capacity
hidden blade this one's actually really
important I didn't know this was a thing
mm-hmm
but if you don't upgrade this you can't
kill higher level things in one hit on
assassinate honest
makes sense so it's not like the other
ones review Sasson a they just die no
matter what gotcha so incentive to
O'Malley be okay if I upgrade that
material did get him something though we
take him some outfits outfits yeah we
can get outfits we have only a few by X
outfit oh yeah
bathhouse dude yeah and then quests that
looks kind of funny though the way he it
looks kind of very off anyways so it's
kind of like The Witcher in that it
separates your main quest side quest
events and completed okay let's just
[Music]
this is the one we can't show yeah but
that main also had some of that stuff in
it and I already showed the map as well
and then people want to see the store
yeah show me that store customize your
character was that dude show me more
info yeah yeah Oh mummy outfit oh we
have 700 credits already I don't know if
we got a unicorn horse use any of these
with me does that do those weapons
actually like count are they just for
sure
oh no they're actually others you can
buy one they're really good too it's
like am i digging some of the aesthetics
here pharaoh scarab you got a you got a
legendary camel all aesthetics though
outside of these weapons i guess right
yeah the weapons seem pretty good though
sleep on hit hell fun kill health for
critical poison hey look really nice to
you alright cool what's that oh you want
to use that bow right it's like a
shotgun yeah look at this bat house look
oh dude you got like five arrows yeah
you shoot like damn that's more than you
could shoot in breath of the wild you
can only shoot a triple shot right or no
did they have a five shot i think then
brought through the world or was it only
triple it was true i think triple right
the one Lionel had the triple I think
can you get these weapons
about this helix cred [ __ ] hard to
say Jacob I don't know if you can get
those exact weapons but it didn't sound
like any legendaries was too difficult
from what
Jake had mentioned like oh you want to
fight bathhouse
back whatever he would I like that your
heads now bleeding no he's not running
away I feel like oh wait yeah yes he was
bleeding oh did you died yeah nice okay
cool
do you know how you get a helix credits
outside of like uh I have no idea okay
it might be there's like a there's like
daily missions you can do I don't know
that was awesome
bird distracts you come from behind and
give them the Big KRIT okay mom the give
them the power strike the else
the l2r to power strike oh you oh that
one is just the charged one Jake failed
me thank you
that's what I want to see exactly that's
what I wanted to see all right guys
that's a more or less a wrap for us in
terms of our a/c origins sidequest the
kind of stream yeah
review later this week review will be
later this week we'll go more in depth
Alessandro is doing that for us so stay
tuned to that thanks Jake for playing
thank you very fun and we have more
streams today a lot more we got another
one at 11:00 for destiny to PC launch
come tune into that if you're into
destiny too and if you want to see
another hot new game that's coming out
this week we'll be doing Wolfenstein 2
later today at 2:00 p.m. that will be me
and John Luke Oh brought the bird back
hold on hold on let me get look at that
yeah yeah let's let's let's end with the
Vic in his in his bass house look and oh
said sinew his bird alright thank you
guys so much I appreciate it
Jake appreciate it if you haven't
followed like subscribe do that stuff so
you guys get notified but until next
time
or in like half an hour see you guys
next time see ya